AT&T has now admitted to paying Donald
Trump's personal lawyer $200,000 for
insights about the Trump administration
and the Trump campaign the payments
stopped right after the Trump FCC
repealed Obama era net neutrality rules
that's not all we learned about payments
to Michael Cohen in the last 24 hours
it also turns out that pharmaceutical
company Novartis paid $400,000 to a
shell company controlled by Donald
Trump's lawyer Michael Cohen and even
more interestingly Michael avenatti
who's the lawyer for adult film star
stormy Daniels he's the person who
initially claimed that the $400,000 in
Novartis payments existed and
specifically that the $200,000 in AT&T
payments were made to Cohen in for
$50,000 installments the timing of the
Novartis payments are also very
suspicious they wrapped up right before
the Novartis CEO had dinner with Donald
Trump in Davos Switzerland
so what's becoming very very clear here
is number one stormy Daniels attorney
Michael avenatti he knows things this
guy seems to be in a position to wreak a
very effective type of havoc which is
called exposing swamp filling corruption
as I like to say and Michael avenatti is
also claiming that Michael Cohen
received half a million dollars from a
company controlled by a Russian oligarch
deposited into the same bank account as
the Novartis money and the AT&T money
Michael avenatti on Twitter saying quote
after significant investigation we have
discovered that mr. Trump's attorney mr.
Cohen received approximately $500,000 in
the months after the election from a
company controlled by a Russian oligarch
with close ties to mr. Putin these
monies have may have reimbursed the
hundred and thirty thousand dollar
payment this is a total of more than a
million dollars two hundred thousand
from AT&T four hundred thousand from
Novartis five hundred thousand from a
Russian oligarch and avenatti says that
he has identified more than four million
dollars in total that flowed through the
bank account at first
Republican bank First Republic Bank or
is it first Republican back now I don't
remember associated with this company
called essential consultants essential
consultants was a company created by
Michael Cohen in 2016 it is the same
company that made the hundred and thirty
thousand dollar hush money payment to
stormy Daniels this is money that was
being sent to Cohen either as an
indirect bribe to Trump although Trump
is a billionaire so would four hundred
thousand here two hundred thousand there
with those gifts really change what he
does maybe not the other possibility is
that this was money being sent to
Michael Cohen with the understanding
that Cohen had Trump's ear and he would
influence Trump either get him a meeting
a dinner a policy this is potential
crony fraud at the highest level the
fact that the AT&T payment stopped when
net neutrality was repealed is very
suspicious the fact that AT&T is
pursuing a merger with Time Warner
something that they need government
approval for is very suspicious AT&T
again is saying this was money paid to
Michael Cohen for campaign insights and
to gain insight into the Trump White
House through Michael Cohen what does
that even mean and if we believe what we
are told that Donald Trump's personal
lawyer Michael Cohen is merely his
personal lawyer that he has nothing to
do with the White House and the
administration why would you pay Michael
Cohen for a hit insight into an
administration he has nothing to do with
none of it makes any sense so at this
point what's clear is that Michael Cohen
is going down and this is growing to be
a scandal of historic proportions this
appears to be part of one of the biggest
ruses hold on the American people that
we've ever reported on for sure and of
course we know what Trump will say Trump
will say he had no idea about the money
going to Michael Cohen he will say
Michael Cohen had no influence over
policy so if people were paying Cohen
for influence that it was a waste of
money he was merely Trump's personal
lawyer so the liability is of course
going to be pushed on to Michael Cohen
is that true I don't know hopefully this
becomes part of Robert Moeller's
investigation these are possible bribes
and as it happens we are talking about
yet another crime with possible
impeachment at the conclude
as the law says the president
vice-president and all civil officers of
the United States shall be removed from
office on impeachment if we run
impeachment for and conviction of
treason bribery or other high crimes and
misdemeanors this should be the story on
corporate media in addition to the Iran
deal which we've already covered this is
the pay-to-play
that Trump accused Hillary Clinton of
and given all of this my instinct is
that Michael Cohen flips the question is
for which prosecutors because this is
now starting to build a very long list
of possible crimes for which prosecutors
are going to want to investigate Michael
Cohen and it's being exposed not as some
bad actors but a coordinated criminal
enterprise and at this point I would
argue it's too big for Robert Moeller's
investigation it's so ironic in a sense
because the right for a while has been
saying a special prosecutor that's
overkill for how little evidence there
is the reality is that there's so much
evidence of possible criminality that it
is too much for Robert Mulder's team
alone to handle they are going to need
to grow the investigative team looking
into what's going on absolutely stunning
revelations over the last 24 hours send
me your thoughts about it I'm on Twitter
at D Pakman and the show is on Twitter
at David Pakman show and we'll be right
back after this support for today's show
comes from ever quote America's largest
online marketplace for auto insurance
only 5% of drivers pay under $50 a month
for auto insurance nationally but ever
quote is helping to change that with a
proprietary matching algorithm that
helps you find the right coverage at the
right price and in fact data shows that
users who find their auto insurance
through ever quote save an average of
five hundred and thirty six dollars per
year
no wonder over three hundred thousand
shoppers use ever quotes insurance
matching services every day take
advantage of ever quotes cutting-edge
data and analytics and go to every quote
dot-com slash Pakman to compare coverage
options to